PAUL IRISH: Hey guys, and
welcome to the first episode
of GDL Presents, wherein we
highlight a developer.
Specifically, we're looking at
developers behind some of the
Chrome experiments as of late.
And today, we have with
us Michael Deal.
Michael is a developer in
Portland, Oregon, an
interactive developer, who's
made some of the
coolest stuff I've seen.
And we're going to take a look
at some of his projects, talk
about how they've been
built, and talk about
how he develops things.
So Michael why don't
you say hello.
MICHEAL DEAL: Hello.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
Nice.
So Michael, you develop
a lot of things.
Tell me about the sort
of products that you
like to work on.
MICHEAL DEAL: I like to work on
projects that have lots of
colors involved.
And audio's an extra bonus.
But colors are kind of
a prerequisite for
a project for me.
PAUL IRISH: I dig it.
So you've done a lot of work
with canvas, SVG, a lot of
audio stuff with web audio API,
and another audio, and a
pretty just comprehensive
set of projects.
So we're going to dive
into a few of them.
But first, I wanted to actually
highlight one of the
things that you did for a site
of ours a little bit ago,
HTML5 Rocks.
You made one of the coolest
tutorials that we've had on
there about typographic
text effects.
And so this was a great article
where we dove into
some of the ways that kind of
show off text, giving it a
neon approach, a stereoscopic
kind of 3D approach.
And so all these manipulations
were just
done in canvas, right?
MICHEAL DEAL: Uh-huh.
Yep.
They're all in canvas.
PAUL IRISH: I think we had a
little demo page where you
could kind of swoop in things.
Oh yeah, it was this.
MICHEAL DEAL: Yeah.
So the different affects, they
ticket heavy usage of the
global composition operation,
which allows you to mesh
layers in different ways.
And this one, in particular,
is more of an
animated text effect.
You can do inner shadows and
outer shadows, glows, all
sorts of things like that.
PAUL IRISH: That's
really cool.
Yeah, this is fantastic.
I actually took some of this
code and I made a little
birthday card for someone--
MICHEAL DEAL: Oh really?
Oh cool.
PAUL IRISH: --using
this approach.
It's a nice and reusable
good quality effect.
MICHEAL DEAL: I'd love
to see that.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Sure.
So yeah, this is great.
So I wanted to dive into one of
your larger projects that I
think people might have seen.
Sketchpad was one of the larger
showcase projects that
we've seen on the Chrome
web store a while ago.
And so this is--
you want to talk about the
application and how it's built
and the functionality that
you have inside of it?
MICHEAL DEAL: Sure.
Yeah, the application was
actually built back in 2008.
And so it's a little bit
of an older project.
But it's held up
well over time.
It takes heavy usage of the
canvas element, as all my
projects do.
And definitely very heavy
on the style.
The styling was probably the
trickiest part, getting all
the different types of gradients
and things working
together in the right manner.
But yeah, it was a really big
learning project for me.
It's where I learned all about
how to really program in
JavaScript and canvas.
That was my first big project.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So, I mean, this is
a big application.
You have a menu with
these fly-out--
it's a little hard to
see on the video.
But we have this really smooth
animation as all these little
non-modal dialogs fly
out, a full toolbar.
How did you go about structuring
the code for this?
MICHEAL DEAL: Structuring?
Well, you know, that's probably
not the best example
of my work.
Because, like I said, I was just
starting to learn how to
put that all together.
But I guess, ever since then in
writing the newer version
of Sketchpad, I've tried to
write everything in a sandbox.
So I'll write one module, one
effect, in a sandbox that's
completely disconnected
from everything else.
And then, after that
I integrate it
into the rest of it.
And what's really been useful to
me, too, is doing different
projects where I can reuse
the project for
different types of things.
And then, the code base gets
a lot cleaner that way.
PAUL IRISH: A common adage is
the key to writing a large
JavaScript application is to
never write a large JavaScript
application.
Break it into the modules
and the libraries.
Yeah.
That's really wise.
MICHEAL DEAL: Totally.
Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: OK, so we won't
view Source on this
application.
MICHEAL DEAL: Yeah.
I should really compress
that, actually.
It's pretty bad.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
Cool.
So we'll go ahead and take a
look at MIDI.js, which is a
really fantastic library that
you put together for taking
MIDI data and piping it out
into sounds through
the Web Audio API.
Is that a good description?
Can you talk about
how it works?
MICHEAL DEAL: Sure.
So the MIDI.js project
allows you to--
there's a back end to it, where
you can encode your own
sound fonts into base64.
So you'll take a sound font--
PAUL IRISH: What's
a sound font?
MICHEAL DEAL: A sound font
is basically any MIDI
application.
Any type of MIDI instrument
has a sound font
representing it.
So if you have a flute, or a
guitar, or a piano, each of
those have their
own sound font.
There's a bunch of different
resources out there where you
can buy sound fonts and
so you can really--
sorry.
PAUL IRISH: No problem.
MICHEAL DEAL: I've got
tea in my teeth, too.
Yeah.
Sorry, what was the
question again?
PAUL IRISH: I was just trying
to understand--
tell me what sound fonts are.
OK, so a sound font is basically
a representation of
an instrument.
They take samples of,
like, a piano at
different types of hits.
And then they combine them
together to make this sound
font that spans the whole
voicing range of a piano.
And the MIDI.js project, it just
basically allows you to
use one of those sound fonts and
then encode it into MP3 or
Aug format.
And then, you can include
it in your project.
It's not a really, really great
representation of the sounds.
But for piano and short hit
instruments, like a guitar, it
works really well.
In the future, as the MIDI API
is actually introduced, that
will be extremely exciting.
I'm not sure if you've heard
about that at all?
But the W3C is actually starting
to put together the
specs for the MIDI API.
PAUL IRISH: For MIDI?
Yeah.
I've seen a little
bit of that.
So MIDI.js is pretty powerful.
And so there's a lot of things
going on inside of it.
The output all goes through
the Web Audio
API, is there right?
MICHEAL DEAL: That's correct.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
And Web Audio API
is somewhat new.
I think it's been out shipping
in Chrome for
about a year or so.
MICHEAL DEAL: Yeah, that
sounds about right.
PAUL IRISH: But just recently,
we heard that Mozilla will be
developing their own
implementation of what Web
Audio API, which resolves a
longstanding kind of situation.
MICHEAL DEAL: With
Audio Video API.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, exactly.
So I think that was good news.
Everyone was pretty
excited about it.
And so with MIDI.js, a few other
people, I think, have
already used this,
is that right?
MICHEAL DEAL: Yes,
that's correct.
A buddy of mine used it to
create a little Simon Says
application.
And another guy created a really
cool application where
you can actually watch MIDI
drop down as if it was the
intro to Star Wars.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
We can actually bring that
up here in this case.
So the project's
called Euphony.
Is that right?
MICHEAL DEAL: That's correct.
PAUL IRISH: And so Euphony
is a Chrome experiment.
And so--
[PIANO PLAYING]
PAUL IRISH: --we can get
a view of it here.
So here we have a MIDI going
through MIDI.js.
I think the visualization
is in 3.js.
And we can pan around
with the mouse.
We can use the scroll wheel to
zoom in and out and get a view
of all the sound as it plays
through the keys.
It's a really cool visualization
of music.
MICHEAL DEAL: They did a really
great job on that.
That really blew my mind.
And he also used Spark.js, which
is another library that
you can use along with 3.js.
PAUL IRISH: And what
does Spark.js do?
MICHEAL DEAL: It's a
particle engine.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, so that handles
when the note hit the
key and it kind of blew up with
a little bit of glow.
MICHEAL DEAL: Exactly.
Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Yup.
That's really great.
Cool.
So inside, I wanted to
touch on Events.js.
And this is a library that
you've written and used in a
few projects.
Could you just give a
description of what
Events.js--
as it is pretty generically
named--
what kind of things does
it capture and
take care of for you?
MICHEAL DEAL: Well, Events.js, I
pretty much include in every
project I do.
It makes it really, really easy
for me to develop for
both mobile and desktop at the
same time without really even
thinking about.
It supports various gestures
like swiping, and rotating,
and pinching, and stuff.
And one cool thing is that you
can actually pinch with 10
fingers or 12 fingers, which
isn't really that useful.
But it's fun.
PAUL IRISH: I think you could
use 10 fingers and a nose.
And actually, recently I heard
that a tongue is conductive.
MICHEAL DEAL: Oh,
there you go.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, so--
MICHEAL DEAL: You can get
11 fingers in there.
PAUL IRISH: If it was a drawing
app, you could draw
with your tongue.
I'm just saying you could.
MICHEAL DEAL: I haven't
tried that yet.
But I definitely will
give that a shot--
PAUL IRISH: Works on iPads.
MICHEAL DEAL: --right after
we're done here.
PAUL IRISH: That's cool.
It's a multi-finger pinch, zoom,
rotate, those kind of
typical gestures that you see.
MICHEAL DEAL: Right.
Right.
And yeah.
PAUL IRISH: And actually, I
think most people don't
understand the capability of
multi-touch JavaScript that we
actually have available.
Not many people think that you
can actually check multiple
touches at the same time and be
able to manifest with that.
But it's actually
not too tricky.
MICHEAL DEAL: No.
It's basically exactly the same
as implementing a regular
touch, or regular pointer
click, except for you're
working with an array.
You're working with three
different arrays.
But you only really have
to work with one array.
So yeah, they did a
really good job of
implementing that, I think.
PAUL IRISH: Great.
OK, so let's take a look at
another one of your projects.
This one is called Sphere.
And Sphere is a way
to kind of view a
series of color palates.
Is that how you'd describe it?
MICHEAL DEAL: Color
harmony formulas.
PAUL IRISH: OK.
Color harmony formulas.
And so we have a different few
formulas to pick from, the
triadic, the five tone,
or the clash.
We can manipulate hue all in
one go, or we can play with
saturation.
But really get an interesting
palette that prescribes to
certain color theory that
I'm not terribly
familiar with, right?
MICHEAL DEAL: And that's one
theme in my project,
generally, is that I don't know
anything about something.
And so I really want
to program it.
And that's how I learn.
Like Color Piano or the Color
Sphere, it's all just a big
learning process for me.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
So yeah, we can take a look
at Color Piano now.
So Color Piano is similar to
what we saw with Euphony.
And we have a 2D visualization
of sound going into keys.
And here, we have a number of
your projects coming into
this, right?
We have MIDI.js, Events,js.
I would take a look at the
script, but it's MIDI-fied, as
it should be.
It's actually not
even coming up.
There we go.
Was there any tricky part
in creating Color Piano?
MICHEAL DEAL: Oh yeah.
It's been a really long
process, actually.
I think I started in 2007 just
toying with the idea.
But the really big problem was
there was no way to make
sounds, make the sound
part of it.
So it would work, like, you
know, you could see, visually,
what was going on, but you
couldn't actually hear what
was going on.
And so I made a little widget
for the canvas,
or the Apple desktop.
And then I made a little API
that ties into Java native
interface, which was cool.
But you had start up Java
to get it working.
And so finally, HTML5 came
out with the audio
tag, which was cool.
But it still sounded like there
was a drunken, I don't
know, a drunken pirate
playing the piano.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, it didn't
pick up on the
responsivity of the audio.
It was higher latency then
you needed it to be.
MICHEAL DEAL: Totally.
Which was kind of artistic and
fun, in a way, hearing my
computer sound like
a drunken pirate.
But it wasn't what
I looking for.
And so when the Web Audio API
came out, the coolest thing,
in my opinion, about it was
that it allows you to plan
notes to hit at exactly
a specific time.
That's what makes it possible.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Yeah, it's great and it's
really well developed.
And you said that Color Piano
is even used in schools.
MICHEAL DEAL: Yeah, that's
what I've heard.
It's really thrilling
to be part of
the educational process.
One theme you might notice in
all my projects is that I try
to teach people stuff.
And so, yeah.
So It was just really
cool to hear.
There was a school in Canada and
then there is a school in
Eastern America.
PAUL IRISH: That's very cool.
So actually, one of the things
that I'm seeing on the Color
Piano, and I see it in a few
of your projects, is this
loading spinner.
That's kind of a common
component that you use across
a few of these apps.
I'm just curious, in this
particular component, how is
it created?
MICHEAL DEAL: That's
a Canvas element.
It uses Bezier curves to create
rounded rectangles.
And it uses the global
composition lighter to blend
the colors together
in a nice way.
And actually, I'll be releasing
that Loader.js sometime.
I could do it this week if
people are interested in it.
But I just haven't gotten
around to it yet.
But that's definitely
in the books.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
That's great.
How do you handle, like, you
have a lot of projects where
you're using new APIs.
How do you handle the situation
of the browser
doesn't support it?
MICHEAL DEAL: Yeah, that's
good question.
I mean, I've definitely gotten a
lot of flack in the past for
not supporting IE6
back in the day.
But Flash Canvas is great.
There's a lot Polyfills
available, as you're aware of.
PAUL IRISH: Do you make use
of these Polyfills?
MICHEAL DEAL: Oh definitely,
like the BlobBuilder API and
request animation frame.
So, yeah, the Polyfills
are a real saver.
Flash Canvas, in particular,
has been really great for
supporting older browsers, like
IE6 and IE7, when using
flash instead.
PAUL IRISH: So it's something.
And I guess these projects you
have a little bit of wiggle
room as far as your
browser support.
But you normally shoot for try
and include IE8 if you can.
But sometimes, depending on
how much audio there is, I
guess you're limited.
MICHEAL DEAL: Absolutley.
I mean, I try to support as
many people as possible.
But there's only so much
time in the day to
support those things.
And it's a lot more
fun to build new
applications, obviously.
It's nice when the browsers
actually support them out of
the box, like IE9, which I'm
pretty stoked about.
And all new browsers really.
It's just such a nice landscape
nowadays compared to
what it was a few years ago.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, it's
definitely getting better.
Great.
And so I wanted to bring up
a more recent project that
you've been working on
recently called--
well, it's your 2.0
of Sketchpad.
And so comparing this to your
earlier version a Sketchpad,
it's a much more modern UI.
Do you want to talk a little
bit about how this one is
constructed and the
feature set here?
MICHEAL DEAL: Sure.
So Sketchpad 2.0 allows you
to create a drawing.
You can undo, redo.
All the layers are stored
in vectors.
So you can change the color.
If you're on a stamp brush,
you can change the type of
stamp you're using.
You can select multiple layers,
change multiple colors
at the same time.
And everything is stored into
JSON on the server, which then
can be recreated later on.
The images, you can drag
and drop images and
SVGs into the browser.
And then, you can play around
with image filters and stuff.
And again, those are
non-destructive as well.
PAUL IRISH: This is great.
And I just noticed you have a
little bit of effects with
these dialogues coming up.
Let me see if I can
load this back up.
Loading.
MICHEAL DEAL: Oh, and I use the
Google font API, which is
really, really fantastic.
There's hundreds of fonts
available for
developers to use.
And the fonts, the text tool is
probably the hardest thing
in there to do, actually.
Because instead of having a text
box and then showing what
the text looks like later, you
can just place your text and
see exactly what it looks like
right on the screen, which
involves figuring out the
metrics of the text, which
isn't available.
But you can find through
tricky CSS and HTML
measurements and stuff.
So it's possible,
which is cool.
It took me a long time
to figure how.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, detecting
the metrics of the text?
MICHEAL DEAL: Yes, to detect
exactly where the text is on
the screen so you can
create a text box.
So that's just a
Canvas element.
Everything's in Canvas.
There's two layers of Canvas.
No divs or anything like that.
PAUL IRISH: So generally, how do
you detect the positioning
of the text?
MICHEAL DEAL: Well, so I've
got a little article on my
website that goes over it.
But basically, you would have
a div, a dummy div.
And you'd put some
text into it.
And then you'd apply text
baseline bottom or whatever.
Different things to measure
different types of things,
like where the center line is,
where the bottom of it is,
where the top of it is.
And then there's
also overhangs.
So sometimes text goes outside
of a box, ascenders and
descenders.
And so for that you have to
actually calculate the pixel.
So you have to run it through a
bounding box calculation to
find out where the actual edges
of the ascenders and
descenders are.
Which is tricky.
PAUL IRISH: Are you taking,
literally, the lowercase x to
determine the x height and
finding out where the pixels
end from a vertical
perspective are?
MICHEAL DEAL: The thing, that
was the original idea.
But the thing is, the x height,
it doesn't really hold
through as much as you'd
hope it would.
But everything's actually
calculated on demand.
So if you write in a paragraph,
then it will
calculate each letter
individually.
It uses the--
I forget.
It uses some sort
of funny text.
Here, let me check it
out real quick.
Refresh.
PAUL IRISH: Oh yeah, I was
going to mention a few of
these dialogues.
We have this nice effect where
it pops the screen out from a
transform perspective.
And these are actually from
another developer?
MICHEAL DEAL: Yes.
That's from Hakim.
He's a developer
over at Qwiki.
And he's just fantastic.
He makes different models.
And he's been putting them out
a lot in the last year.
And they really make your
application just pop.
My application didn't really
look that cool.
And then I threw
that in there.
And all of a sudden I was like,
wow, this is so cool.
PAUL IRISH: It's look great.
It has a really good affect.
MICHEAL DEAL: It's super
appreciated that you he puts
that stuff out there for us.
PAUL IRISH: So--
MICHEAL DEAL: But yeah, it's
Meny.js and avgrund.js.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, OK.
Meny.js?
M-E-N-Y.js and avgrund,
A-V-G-R-U-N-D.js and he's got
a bunch of other cool things
in there, too.
PAUL IRISH: Very cool.
So I wanted to ask you a little
bit of how you actually
do your development.
What is your workflow
as far as the
editor that you're using?
Do you use Lyntin?
How do you iterate
on your project?
Do you write unit tests
for these apps?
That kind of development
experience of these things.
MICHEAL DEAL: Sure.
Well, I definitely think unit
tests are a really great idea
and it's something that I'm
going to get into soon,
because otherwise you're
going to get OCD.
Or not OCD, but repetitive
stress
problems with your wrist.
But so I do all my programming
in DBEdit right now.
I tried to switch over
to Sublime Text.
But the DIF wasn't quite
up to my standards.
But Sublime Text is looking
really, really cool.
But right now I'm still using
DBEdit for everything.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
And do you use source
control locally?
Are you using something
like JSHint or JSLint?
Just to check your sanity
as far as when
you're writing code?
PAUL IRISH: I use jsbeautifier
to make my code pretty.
But as I far as sanity checking
, I take it into
older browsers to see
if it breaks.
And then go from there.
But I mean, that's definitely
another thing that I probably
should be doing.
But I haven't been.
PAUL IRISH: Understandably.
Yeah, I mean, I ask because
with applications of this
scale, it starts
to get tricky.
You'll have a bug.
And you think you fixed it.
And it'll come back.
It's a little tricky
to manage.
So you mentioned before, you
find yourself writing your
apps as far as smaller
libraries and
modules coupled together.
What's your system for building
out those central
components?
MICHEAL DEAL: Well, I
like to start a new
project as much as possible.
It's really nice, because
it just clears my mind.
When you're working on a really
big project, you have
all this stuff loaded
into your mind.
And there's just
so many things.
But if you can get it into a
small component, like just
some sort of an effect or
something, then it just makes
it so much more simple.
So I put everything
in a sandbox.
And then I just plug away
at it from there.
But actually, for my SVG
support, I did do some sort of
testing where you can put
the SVG in there.
Then to the left of that,
you'll see what it
looks like in Canvas.
Then you'll look to the
bottom of that.
And you'll see what it looks
like in Canvas re-rendered
through my VOB format.
And then on the bottom right,
you can see what it looks back
in SVG after it goes
back all around.
And it's supposed to look
the same both ways.
So visual testing, I've done
that a little bit, which is
really handy.
I'm more of a visual guy.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So you make use of a lot of
really great techniques.
Where do you pick up
these techniques?
What sites are you reading,
people do you follow to keep
track of that sort of stuff?
MICHEAL DEAL: Oh gosh, back in
the day it used to be Ajaxian.
That was really cool.
Badass JS is cool.
Creative JS is great.
Twitter is amazing.
Twitter seems to be the place
right now to really get
inspired and see everything
that's happening, if you
follow people like you.
There's all sorts of great
people out there
posting these things.
Chrome experiments, obviously,
you get a lot
of inspiration there.
I mean, I just basically try
to keep a pulse on what's
going on as much as possible.
And I just focus on trying to
stay up to date as much as
possible as to what
people are doing.
It's really mind blowing what
people are doing nowadays.
It's just insane.
I'm really impressed with
the 3D work, especially.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, yeah, having
all the 2D graphics APIs that
we have now combining with
what's available on audio and
the experience is getting pretty
heavy pretty quick.
Pointer lock just landed in
Chrome a little bit ago.
That's more of a 3D thing.
But there's a lot going on.
So it's pretty exciting.
MICHEAL DEAL: Yeah, it's so
nice that you can finally
control, basically, all the
outputs the computer has.
You've got the audio control.
You've got the pixel control.
And so you can do, basically,
most things you need to do.
The file management's still
not quite there.
But they're making a lot
of progress on it.
It's really cool to see all the
new things they're doing
there, too.
And obviously, connecting into
MIDI ports and stuff like
that, game control API, which is
really interesting as well.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
Well this is great.
And so I encourage everyone to
go and check out your blog.
It's over at MUDCU.be
MICHEAL DEAL: MUDCUBE.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
It's on MUDCUBE.
You'll find it.
And so it goes through
all your projects.
We went through the
older Sketchpad
and the newer Sketchpad.
But you also ported
this to mobile.
It's called Sketch Mobile and
has a new interface that's
designed exclusively for touch
and smaller screens.
So it's fantastic.
And it walks through a lot of
your other projects and all
the stuff that you put out
there, including the colored
website and community that we
didn't even get a chance to
touch on today.
But they have a lot.
It's a great community around
color, color palates.
Probably the best gradient
creation tool that I've seen
is inside colored.
So excellent stuff.
So I encourage everyone to--
MICHEAL DEAL: Thank
you so much.
That was a collaborative project
with my buddy Daniel
Christopher, who works
right next to me.
We've been working together
for the last 12
years a little bit.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
Cool.
And so follow Michael on both
GitHub and Twitter, at MUDCUBE
on G+, @MichealDeal.
And that's about it.
So Michael, thank you very
much for joining us.
This has been fantastic.
MICHEAL DEAL: Well, thank you
so much for having me.
You guys have a great day
and enjoy the rest
of the summer here.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
We will.
Awesome.
Thanks very much.
Bye.
MICHEAL DEAL: All right.
Take care.
Bye-bye.